our first panelist is professor of
linguistics and the executive director
of the Center for teaching research and
learning at American University
please welcome Naomi Barron next is the
Paulette
Godard chair of digital median learning
Sciences and a professor in the spine
heart School of culture education and
human development here at NYU please
welcome John Fox joining us is associate
professor of Child and Adolescent
Psychiatry
at NYU School of Medicine and clinical
psychologists and neuropsychologist at
the Child Study Center of the NYU
Langone Medical Center
please welcome dr. Richard Gallagher
last but not least we have postdoctoral
fellow in the Department of Psychology
at Temple University who's also a
visiting associate assistant professor
at Haverford College
please welcome Loren Shermer so we start
with a couple of Givens we're all social
creatures as humans and recent research
suggests that social interaction in
small and larger groups has may have
play a key role in our evolution and
survival and fanning out across the
planet but that all happened in a very
different environmental landscape we
know that in other cases take the
obesity epidemic in the United States
where we were evolved not to live in a
land of of coca-cola and french fries
there's there's consequences when the
nature of the environment around us
change changes and for sure that's
happened with social interaction with
digital media and online platforms so
first from each of you I'd love to hear
what you think the headline is about how
social and digital media are affecting
young people in particular as they grow
up in the world today let's start with
you Naomi you've done research on how
social media is affecting children and
teenagers reading and in other effects
what's your biggest headline
finding the biggest finding as far as I
can tell now and I'm saying that because
we really don't have nearly enough
research is we assume that reading
digitally is no different from reading
in print we don't know that for a fact
my major concern is that the devices on
which we do our digital reading are
devices that were designed for very
different kinds of activity and we can
call it interactive activity sometimes
socially interactive sometimes
interactive with sites but it's activity
that leads you to spend a very small
amount of time on a on a particular
screen worth it leads you to multitask
it doesn't lead you to sit back and
concentrate which is what in principle
not always in practice but in principle
print allowed us to do so my major
concern my headline is until we really
know how to train people to take the
mindset of reading in print and use it
reading digitally we're going to be
incredibly shallow readers and there's
some studies that have been done that
can suggest that's what's happening
Lauren you studied the effects of social
media on the teenage and adult brain in
real-time
can you describe your experience and
experiments yeah so it was really
surprising to me that up until very
recently nobody had actually looked to
see what's going on in the brain when
adolescents are really people of any age
we're using social media and so we have
all these questions right we want to
know what are the effects of social
media what are the effects of Technology
on the brain and so you'd think a very
first step would just be to say all
right let's put someone in the MRI
scanner and let's see what's going on in
their brain when they use social media
and maybe the reason that it wasn't done
is because it's actually not so simple
because if we think about social media
there are media there are many different
things right and many experiences that
you have whether it's on Facebook or
writing a blog are indeed very complex
and so as much as it's nice that you can
be in the MRI scanner and you see a
little
screen in front of you we like to have
experiments in the MRI that are very
simple that are very controlled and so
it actually was a little bit hard to get
from this really rich complex experience
on your computer or your phone to
something that we can look at in the
scanner and what was really exciting to
me when I was trying to think about okay
how do we do this where do we start
right around the time that I was
thinking about this question Instagram
started to become really popular with
teens and the thing that's cool about
Instagram is it takes what previously
was very complicated if you think about
Facebook that you have several feeds at
the same time lots of text Instagram
suddenly makes it very simple so you
have a picture you have a little bit of
information about that picture maybe the
likes and the number of comments and so
the question that my colleagues and I
decided to look at is say you're looking
at a picture on Instagram but you look
at this picture and it has maybe two or
three likes and then your peer looks at
the same picture and now they see it and
it has 50 likes how is this little bit
of information how is this number going
to change the way that you respond to
the picture are you more likely to like
it if it's popular and how is it going
to change the way that you take in
information is your brain response to
that picture actually going to change
and we zeroed in on this idea of the
like because it's something that really
is brand new right so for a very long
time we've been telling each other how
we feel about information if I'm up here
in front of you and I'm telling you a
joke I get sort of an idea of your
response based on your smiling or your
laughter but now we have this really
interesting new context where I'm
getting a number that's associated with
something that I've created or something
I've put out into the world and so what
we found is that this little number the
number of likes on a photo affected how
likely teens were to like the pictures
so they were significantly more likely
to click like I use the word like a lot
when I talk about this they're
significantly more likely to click like
on the picture if they believe that many
of their peers have also liked it so we
got this peer influences kind of
happening in a new way online and then
we also saw that their brain response
was changing that when they looked at a
picture that had a lot of likes versus a
few they showed more activation in a
number of different parts of the brain
parts of the brain that are involved in
social cognition
and thinking about your world parts of
the brain that are involved in visual
perception so even though they're seeing
the same thing the parts of the brain
that process visual information are
becoming more active which suggests
maybe they're scanning it a little more
carefully paying attention to it in a
different way and then the really
interesting thing that we find is that
parts of the brain that are involved in
reward and reinforcement so getting a
reward responding to that reward being
motivated to do something in the future
these parts of the brain were becoming
more active when they saw that a picture
had a lot of likes and especially if
they saw that their own picture had a
lot of likes as I'm sure you can imagine
so it's basically saying likes are like
chocolate or sex or correct and how is
this new yeah I was this different than
what teenagers have been doing subtly
for thousands or millennia so so what's
particularly new about digitality of
this yeah I mean that's kind of an open
question to some extent it is something
that has already existed right so the
idea that peers are being influenced
this is absolutely not something that is
new the idea that peers are very
motivated by what or that adolescents
are very motivated by what their peers
think is certainly something that
already was happening for a long time
and so some of the questions that were
really interested in exploring because
again this is something we don't know a
lot about is is this something that is
really new or are we just seeing this
kind of recapitulation of what we
already knew about adolescents there are
some things that make social media very
different one is that now there are
these numbers associated with
information so the experience that you
get of seeing that people are liking you
it's a little bit more like a currency
right now it's quantifiable and so
that's kind of a big question is this in
any way changing the experience of
getting information from your peers and
what's great about your experiment was
that it was an experiment you actually
manipulated a number of lights the
photos got so you you basically control
the popularity yes currency there but
the the cost of doing experiment is that
you're seeing something in your fMRI or
or any other measures in real time
that's perhaps a short-lived effect yes
Richard as a
child and adolescent psychiatrist you're
seeing sort of work globally the
longer-term effects of the cumulation of
these kind of dopamine surges and
disappointments and so forth and
multitasking and what it's doing to our
memory and all those kind of things so
are you seeing more ADHD more social
disorders more mutism what are you
seeing well I think what's really
important about these different forms of
social of their digital tools is that
they're one of the headlines that I like
to be able to provide our work is work
oftentimes in terms of summarizing what
we have been finding out in the research
and I think it's really important for
everybody to think about them as tools
that are for communication for
entertainment and for education and that
just like other tools they have
advantages and disadvantages and I think
that some of the debate that has been
around about some of the negative
aspects of digital media and digital
tools is that there's like some global
effect that is all in one direction so
there's debate about the positives
there's debate about the negatives and
what's really true is that people are
pretty variable and that there are
positives and negatives and it does
impact keep people in different fashions
so that we do see that some persons in
getting heavily involved with games do
end up having more difficulties with
their attention especially if they are
engaged with these activities at a young
age and if they get involved a lot of
this activity there's in fact a
dose-response relationship in some of
the studies there's an indication that
if you're involved with gaming for about
an hour a day it seems to enhance your
attention if it's more than three hours
a day then it starts to deteriorate and
it has an impact about lots of other
activities that require some attention
the same thing can be true with social
media it depends about how you interpret
the information persons that get
involved there's a lot of concern about
Facebook and seeing how wonderful
everybody else is and like how
diminished your life is in comparison if
people approach it with an envious way
of dealing with things it does result in
more anxiety and depression for
adolescents than if people just say well
this is interesting and I'm not going to
be too concerned about where I put Mary
stand so I think the headline I would
like to present is that we need to be
careful we need to gather a lot more
information to know about the positives
negatives and also the impact it has on
people individually just a push at one
point you said so let's take the example
of the kid who games for more than three
hours a day how do we know and let's say
they exhibit signs of depression or
loneliness or inattention how do we know
that's not the gaming is not the effect
and not the cause there's a there's a
good number of longitudinal studies
there clearly is an indication that for
example in clinical populations kids
with attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder are more prone to get involved
gaming but in terms of some little
longitudinal studies looking at kids at
one time point and a later time point
there is an indication that they get
more involved with problems with
attention if you know after extensive
amounts of you I'm also aware of another
study maybe you were involved this
Florin where they they send kids off to
camp
for a little under a week and one group
they took away their media and the other
group they let them keep it at the end
of course the ones without the media had
a better time but they can also actually
perform better on measures of social
cognition yeah reading other people's
emotions empathy etc so you would that's
consistent with what you're seeing in a
clinic well oftentimes yes now again
there's also benefits for some kids that
are socially isolated for some kids that
have a little bit of difficulty with
some of their social skills some aspects
of social media and some aspects of
games that involve some social
interaction especially the multiplayer
games sometimes that's better that that
sometimes results of the kids sometimes
becoming more out of their shell and
actually establishing good community
across boundaries especially when they
have very particular interest yeah yeah
you know Wiccan golfers of Northeast
okay I think young you have a more
positive headline for us so you were
kind of mixed if so we're gonna end with
the positive as I was looking to
everybody I tried to decide if I should
come down and the positive or the
negative side your only hope
yes obi-wan I'm going to I'm going to
start with the positive side because we
can always go back to the negative side
that's always so easy and I'm gonna tell
you why I want to start with the
positive side but let me start by by
saying my headline is that we live in an
age that is unprecedented
as far as the educational opportunities
are concerned that our children have not
just in this country but all over the
world based on things that are designed
in this country and all over the world
and so I do not just mean that we have
information at all fingertips on the web
I also mean that we have simulations in
which you can explore scenarios that you
don't directly have access to we have
games that can motivate those who have
decided to disengage from something that
they felt wasn't really of interest to
them we have so many genres now of
educational environments available to us
that teachers nowadays are almost
complaining about the wealth of
different information and they don't
know how to choose from that that did
not use to be the case when I was in
school I very clearly remember not ever
having any of those tools and and some
of the adults in the room probably that
resonates with you so we have not only
this unprecedented time of wealth of
information and high-quality information
coming directly from the source from
NASA from from all the fun kind of
organizations that that have done the
research are now presenting the results
but we also are entering an age of well
shall I say accountability but what I
really mean with that is an age where
there's a quantification in a positive
sense of what how we're actually doing
and so what we're seeing is there was
first to quantified self movement in
terms of now you know how many steps you
took today which is exciting or I know
how many miles I ran or bikes this week
which is also exciting but we're
starting to see
adaptive learning engines that come out
that tell you what your memory strength
is about what you've learned where you
good at what you're not good at and so
we're entering this this age where we
get feedback about our learning
personalized not as a group which is
easy right but personalized that open a
number of opportunities that we only
barely starting to to understand and so
I said I would give you an example I'm
gonna keep it short
we just finished a study with Syrian
refugees in Turkey as you know there's a
huge crisis in Syria lots of families
millions had to leave their homes Turkey
is one of the countries that took in the
most of those refugees and they're
living in camps so the opportunities to
learn would have been very very limited
had it not been for digital media so we
were asked to help out and we designed a
four-week curriculum where there studied
for two hours a day for five days a week
for four weeks we taught them how to
code we taught them how to learn Turkish
do it because you cannot get into school
if you don't know the language we added
cognitive skills training especially
executive functions training and because
there's a lot of hopelessness and lack
of positive outlook we added a game that
actually gives you full control over
your in my environment some of you guys
might be playing at Minecraft and so so
we had this curriculum that is largely
based on off entirely based on digital
media and largely on games and we saw
after four weeks so many positive
indications of having an and positive
impact on that that we're now seeing to
scale this app and so if one wants to
look on the positive side those are some
of the examples that I would want to
give I mean I volunteer for a
online-only tuition for University Coll
University of the people that's trying
to reach the same underserved
populations but you're also teaching at
NYU and you're teaching both digitally
only and in the classroom in this
brick-and-mortar sense what did it take
home headline lessons if someone was
going to try to develop pedagogical
games online
yeah that's that's a really loaded
question let me start by saying that I
do not believe that entire curricular
should be game based more recently
refused games for brain training kind of
a topic that is a little bit
controversial ever since Lumosity got
fined 52 million dollars for making
false claims about how effective they
are so we decided well let's look at
that as researchers right we were
interested in that executive functions
is underlying almost everything we do
right now you're you're using all of
your executive functions you're
inhibiting the desire to do something
else perhaps you're using your working
memory your shifting function is when
different people talk and have different
ideas then you shift its cognitive
flexibility involved so it's something
that we do for almost everything we do
have thought and action and emotion and
it can be trying that's the good news
it's also something that as Stewart
children who don't have parents who can
spend a lot of time with them because
they may need to work two or three jobs
they don't get the opportunities to
train their executive functions which is
one reason why we see a new achievement
gap in schools so what if we had a game
that could train your executive
functions and was actually a fun game to
play in so we build some of those we're
testing them what we're doing is design
research so we compare two different
versions we say here you know we
actually worked with 11:00 to 2:00 or 12
to 15 16 year-olds a lot we give them
the games and and they day to play two
different versions one might be adaptive
one might not be one that has different
game characters than the other etc and
then we look at which one works better
and in the end we see what the overall
outcome is on academic achievement does
it actually enhance your performance in
school etc and and if that's all the
case then they are available for free on
our website you can play them at your
heart's desire and see if that works for
you that's that I think it was too much
positive now I know a few years ago
there was a study at UCLA that divided
people into learning something while
they were multitasking and and the other
group of course were directed to have
their full attention on
not on the task of learning of
memorizing something and it not only did
the ones that gave their full attention
of course do better
unruhe call and and learning a task they
actually encoded it in their brain
differently so they the the multitaskers
they found that the air striatum was
more activated and and it was encoded as
procedural memory which is like driving
a car where it's a habit but you're not
as conscious of it and the people who
focused store the new knowledge and the
new skill as declarative memory in the
hippocampus and the the benefit of
declarative memory is that allows you to
abstract from the particular to the
general so if you know how to drive a
car maybe you don't know how to drive a
motorcycle or a plane but if you know
how to solve a proof you know for
partial differential equation you might
be able to transfer that to something
else that has the same basic logical
framework so are we all
Lauren we are looking at you but anyone
can jump in I'll be one of the
consequences of the enormous number of
hours that we have our devices with us
and our on them and particularly young
people are we increasingly becoming kind
of rote machines where we learn how to
do things through procedural memory and
that doesn't sound really great for the
age of the coming BOTS where we really
need to think in a more abstract level
to to justify our usefulness over a
robot so I what are you finding in your
research are what what are the
consequences of multitasking or
continuous partial attention yeah I
haven't studied multitasking in
particular most of the stuff I've looked
at is more in code the social domain as
opposed to the cognitive although the
really interesting thing about
smartphones is now you're multitasking
with social information as well and with
multitasking it sort of does depend on
the kind of multitasking so if you are
task switching very rapidly in certain
cases you're not actually able to
multitask and what we think of as
holding two things in your mind you're
going back and forth and so as you
mentioned that there are some
disadvantages to doing that on the other
and there are certain ways that if
you're multitasking during a videogames
if you're playing sort of an action
video game where you have a lot of
information in the environment you have
to keep track of if it's a first-person
shooter for example those are situations
where you might have someone over here
and over there and now you are
multitasking in the sense that your
attention is focused in multiple areas
and the really interesting thing is that
there's some research that finds that
those kinds of games do improve your
ability to hold information in your mind
at once and so when we say multitasking
it really depends on what we're talking
about because on the one hand you get
people who are gamers are actually
better at one kind of multitasking on
the other hand people who tend to report
that they do a lot of using social media
while they're doing homework and that
sort of thing that they often will show
lower performance on certain tasks so
again it's this idea that it really
depends on how you define it that there
are these benefits or decrements but
it's it's not one thing even with
multitasking interestingly when you
survey this because some surveys were
done a couple of years ago and you asked
high school students when you multitask
do you think that your performance
academically what you're sitting doing
your homework is degraded they'll say no
no no no yeah I think unless someone
here knows more it's really only the
first-person shooter action video games
that are suggesting that you can get
good at that kind of multitasking so
you're entirely right you have to think
about what do we mean by multitasking if
your players are you saying that if I
let my son play first first-person
shooter video games then he'll be able
to know I wouldn't count on it and he'll
be able to do the first-person shooter
games really well and we really don't
know about transferability to other
domains we know there's certain kinds of
activities that go together if you play
the piano you need two hands and you
need your feet okay is that multitasking
it is in the version because all you
have to do is look at someone learning
to play the piano to begin with and you
can't coordinate both hands I'll never
forget when mice
my son to drive he said I'll look ahead
and you look in the mirrors for me
because I can't do both and then
eventually you learn you have to
coordinate those pieces there has been
research that suggests there certain
people maybe 2 to 5 percent of the
population who are super tasker's who
actually can do well in multitasking but
the experiments that were done at
Stanford a number of years ago said the
people who say I'm really good at
multitasking were probably worse in fact
the data shed work showed were worse
than the people said I'm sorry I can't
keep track of multiple things at the
same time but there's one other point
I'd like to make if I could and that has
to do with what is that we mean by
learning and part of the question about
whether digital technologies are helping
us learn or not is that on the one hand
digital technologies are really good for
finding facts or for finding pieces of
information which may be collections of
facts and we use the technologies for
getting those little pieces however if
we don't have a context that says
there's more to learning than this
there's something we want to call
knowledge there's something that's
called 2 years from now how did you
integrate those pieces that you learn
then I think we're missing out an
important part of what learning should
be about the same thing I think goes for
adaptive learning for certain subjects
that can be absolutely superb and far
better than the vast majority of
teachers most of us have had on the
other hand one of the problems are one
of the challenges of adaptive learning
is if we say this could work in any
discipline you then have to say for
doing philosophy how do you make that
adaptive for a learning tool and are
those the things that are most important
to learn in philosophy or is it a way of
thinking about problems and I don't know
that we know how to code that into
smaller pieces and if you can figure it
out
please help I'm not sure I can figure
that's something that in this moment but
I can say that the term adaptive
learning evokes certain people and
certain ideas and sort of
and and from just just listening to how
you describe it I I can imagine how you
would think about it and and I imagine
everybody else here has a different
opportunity as a different experience
and what adaptive might have meant and
that's the problem with adaptivity and
personalization is this other buzzword
that we're using right now personalized
learning adaptive learning
individualized learning and nobody
really knows what the differences are or
better yet everybody has their own
definition but uses those words
interchangeably so at apptivity the way
I would describe it means that any
learner at any time gets what that
learner needs to succeed right and if
that is applied to philosophy that would
mean entirely different things then if I
learn math or language right but we
don't know how to do that yeah right so
we have and and I developed just to
explain it to myself I developed this
taxonomy which is in a kind of
categories of how one could do adaptive
learning and when you look at that
entire taxonomy there may be thirty
different ways of doing that alone on
the cognitive domain but then we have
the affective domain we have a social
cultural domain we have we have
motivational domains of where where we
could adapt that way right and so when
you look at that and when you look at
the existing adaptive systems when we're
talking about intelligent tutoring
systems and other systems that kind of
try to guess to predict what you need
and mostly that means you just solve
this problem this math equation so
you're now ready to solve this math
equation that's a little harder right
that would never work in philosophy but
that's just such a small part of what I
have to meet with me but as as
researchers as learning scientists were
just in the beginning of understanding
that or understanding how to build it we
understand what we would love to have
but not how to do it understanding what
it does mean to be multitasking because
you know the definition is probably not
clear enough what's often described as
multitasking is really switching from
one activity to another there are some
benefits for multitasking that have been
documented in in work with kids and
other persons for examples it in a
colleague of mine did some work a good
number of years ago on the idea of
helping kids with attention problems and
trying to see what happens if they
listen to music as they're doing their
work if they select the music
they actually do improve their
productivity it seems the kind of the
brain is multitasking there's one part
that's kind of attending to the music
sort of like activating the brain and
making it like occupy kind of keep it
occupied more like an idling in the car
the car is ready to move up and to
advance it when they present to a
problem and the same thing has been
found with adults when they're involved
with doodling and listening to lectures
yes it is true but like but doodling it
does result in people paying better
attention to lectures that are being
presented so I think we have to be
really careful about these definitions
because we can't get overly broad in
that regard and get confused so you're
in the business of actually giving the
best practices to two families the
parents of how to manage this brave new
world that's exploding upon us so what
are some of the points what are some of
the basic things that given all this
kind of context specificity on the one
hand on the other hand what do you tell
us to do with our kids well I think one
thing that's really important is to be a
bit more very conscious of what we are
talking about to be really tuned into it
and to UM not I think one thing that has
happened is that we think that this
technology is not understandable and
that it's like so brand-new that it
can't be put into a context and perhaps
I'm being too simplistic and maybe
that's the way the mind mind works but I
do think that it's really helpful for
people to say well many of these
instruments are means of communication
you know so what do you think about the
role of communication in your children's
lives and what kind of communication do
you want them to have there's there
tools for education what kind of
education what kind of content you want
to have your kids learn about and what
what methods of what things do you want
them to be involved with in terms of
leisure and I like to be able to suggest
to parents that they think about you
know for example with education you can
use digital resources to be able to
learn how to be you know some really
problematic issues you can you can learn
to be a really good anorexic you can
learn to be a good bomb maker you can
also do all the different kinds of
fascinating things have been presented
here
already I was grout the communication
you can get really good at being a bully
you can also get really good at being
able to communicate to people in Alaska
and you know in Africa and many other
communities and you can really make a
good sign a set of connections and with
leisure time you can spend you know most
of your time on junk and things that are
not going to be very very useful or you
can do it on some things that are
fulfilling and a little bit of junk and
so I think when parents do that and
think about these things is similar to
what they were presented as kids and
that I think that helps kind of like put
the context into it that's really very
useful how how is a parent to control
all of this I mean who Dana Boyd and my
research argues that actually think all
of the stuff like the specific teen talk
that parents can't decode on social
media sites and so forth is all a
response to the fact that we over
program and over control our kids today
not an effect but actually I sorry not
actually cause but the effect of what
we're doing already in trying to kind of
control their worlds I mean I'm I'm I'm
not only defriended for my sons right
I'm blocked so what what is like what am
I to do well I think you know the thing
is you know kids and adolescents have
always found some way to keep seeing a
secret the question is like how secret
and how problematic you know I work in a
clinical setting you don't want to be
the parent and this is a number of years
ago when things were just starting to
find out that your 12 year old daughter
has gotten really obsessed with
something and really concerns showing a
lot of signs of anxiety because what has
happened is she met somebody at camp the
boy has been sexting with her and that
she's like now preoccupied and she
doesn't know how to stop it and you
don't want to be the parent that finds
out that when you go to Verizon and find
out okay here's the series of texts and
has been going on for months you don't
want to be the parent that finds out
that your teenage son and these are
these are cases has been involved with
staying up and chatting and texting into
you know 5:00 in the morning
with the girl that's suicidal you want
to be able to have some sense of what is
going on you don't even know each and
every detail but you have to know the
trends well I think what you do is you
do kind of like recognize that these
again our tools you know like an example
I give in my talks is that you know week
we have chainsaws and chainsaws are very
useful they're very helpful they can
help us do a lot of different things but
then you have the chest at Texas
Chainsaw Massacre it can be used in a
different way not to just think about is
being something that you can't step into
not to think that like okay every kid
and I've had some situations where
people are saying eight-year-olds have
an inalienable right to privacy well
really did you grow up that way did your
parents raise you that way I mean we've
been parenting for a long time and I
think we have to try to be logical and
reasonable to say well I do need to know
a little bit of the trend I do need to
know what's going on I do need to be
tuned in enough to be aware of what
you're doing and during the technology
tools that we sometimes feel are so
overwhelming that we don't even want to
start to understand what our children
are doing can also be used to help with
that right so I have my favorite app on
my phone is the one that lets me turn
off the Wi-Fi and the Wi-Fi in our house
is tightly controlled because both of my
kids would be on at all times if I
didn't and for a while we collected the
devices and then they got really smart
and they were hiding them so now you can
hide your iPod as much as you want but
the Wi-Fi is often it's on for Sonia or
phones with 4G well so there's that
right so you need to you need to look at
you need to look at all the different
ways of how your children manage to get
the information that they want to get
but what I'm saying is that is and I
think that's what's point that that has
always been the case we just have to not
give up and give in to say well
technology it's it's just so hard to
understand what these kids do nowadays
so we just let them do anything and
what's interesting is my 14 year old and
probably shouldn't mention this may be a
poor guy but he will tell me about other
kids in his class that have far more
control over their digital life than he
does and and he says it half admiring
and half kind of you know understanding
why he does not get that from
he's also the one who asked me that you
do research on games for learning why
don't we have an Xbox or a ps4 on our
house and you know it's the same reason
the other reason is that my office is
right across the street you know but you
know so we need to take charge in
there's a new digital literacy on the
part of the parents involved and a new
digital literacy on the part of the
children involved that we need to teach
them about because the kind of things
that they're posting before they have
found out what can happen are kind of
hair-raising sometimes and so I'm not
gonna because this is gonna be I don't
feel my secret ways adapt to kids or 11
and 14 so I want to interview you again
in four years and see if you still can
do that it's minor 17 and 19 but and and
yes everybody's learning about what you
should or should not text or post and
you know understanding that you're on a
public stage part of part of the problem
with social media or the it's a problem
but is is the erasure of what
sociologists Erving Goffman called front
stage and backstage where intimate
private things were done backstage in
fact I that created intimacy by letting
people in to your secrets and front
stage was how you behaved here on front
stage but is that being eroded Lauren
like is it well they're a blur are
people still managing to maintain fun
and backstage high social I mean I think
that it as with everything kind of
depends and I can think of examples of
teenagers actually using social media in
a way that they divide that into a front
stage and backstage so even just
thinking about the different social
media that teens use what's been really
interesting to me and I haven't been
doing this research for all that long
but in the time that I've been doing it
seeing how the tools have changed and
seeing what is popular so when I started
doing my work on Instagram it was before
too many teens were using it and by the
time I was finished it was very popular
and teenagers had Facebook's but they
are boring and they didn't really use
them and since then and talking to
adolescents they describe it as it's a
little bit more like LinkedIn where I
think at some point there was this
message that colleges are going to
your Facebook and so teens started
thinking about it as oh yes well a
college is gonna look at my facebook so
it has to look very nice and you know
they're thinking of it is this way that
they present themselves to the world
whereas something like Instagram which
nowadays many many teens have instagrams
on private so it's not something that
most of the world can see now it doesn't
mean that there's no possibility that
something they post could ever get out
there but I think it's definitely true
that adolescents are very aware of one
not always but but they do often have an
awareness of when something is private
or not when something is again ephemeral
or not so this it was really fascinating
to me when snapchat became so popular
because for a long time what we talked
about is the idea that social media and
the internet is there it's always
available and that in the case of
cyberbullying for example that you go
home and you still see this horrible
message that somebody posted and so the
things that we worried a lot about this
idea that information didn't go away now
was kind of being flipped on its head
and I think that's why snapchat was so
exciting for teens and you see what was
really funny is when snapchat became
popular I think a lot of parents worried
that it would be used for sexting right
because it's you take a picture or a
video and then it disappears and so you
can immediately think of what that might
be used for and instead what teenagers
use it for was to take really stupid
pictures of their faces and send them to
each other
and so it's this idea that it's more
casual and it's not something that has
to look very beautiful and perfect and
now we're also looking face to face on
these tools so you mentioned the study
by my colleague Alda who was looking at
when kids had their devices basically
taken away and they went to camp for a
week and then at the end of that they
showed that they were better able to
read facial expressions and understand
prosody and voices that's what he was
done I think maybe five or six years ago
now and I really wonder if the study was
done again now if the same effects would
be found because we've moved from a very
text-based tool to tools where they're
very audio-visual in nature so that's
getting a little far afield of your
question but I think privacy to get back
to that is something that adolescents
really do think about and they navigate
or at least they may
become more interested in tools because
of the affordances as related to privacy
so I don't think it's true that that's
disappeared I think it's just it looks a
little different now yes one of the
questions that's been raised a couple of
times is is it different in social media
than it whatever it is where it is in
the rest of the world
and at this point I'll put my linguist
hat on and say one of the things we know
about learning to use language
particularly by the time you get to be a
teenager and somewhat younger for many
of these other skills if you are really
good at knowing what you say to whom
when and you know there are certain
kinds of things you will say to your
parents that you will not say to your
friends and vice versa that you will say
to some friends but not other friends
there have been studies done going to
this front stage backstage behavior
issue there are people who will say I'll
use certain what used to be emoticons
and now it's probably emojis or gifs and
I'll use certain events with some people
but I'll use others with other people so
we know that by the time you're 10 11
and definitely by the time you're 14 to
15 you have a lot of these skills of
shifting registers as it's called in
what you say and how you say it to whom
so this question of being able to
control your own behavior if you choose
to is something you already have another
skill for and you're just translating it
you know other it's with words or
whether it's of visual images that works
the same way but there's just one other
point that I wanted to make that comes
to what I'll call the technological
determinism argument it's very easy to
think this new technology is here it's
going to take us over and we have to
some extent said that with a lot of
digital media what can I do it's going
to happen and you know in the room that
I live in it's Oh digital texts are
going to come you know print is over or
this what can I do as a parent I have no
choice
well of course you have choices and does
that mean there won't be some
disagreements
there'll be disagreements but there were
disagreements about driving cars there
were disagreements about alcohol there
were disagreements about
your hairstyle there were disagreements
about when you get a phone there were
disagreements about are you allowed to
drink I mean these have been gone on
going on for a long time the difference
here is now there's this device you can
carry in your hand and you can do a lot
more things you hope in private than you
could before but that but the issues
haven't changed and the responsibilities
that we have whether we're parents or
teachers haven't changed it's just try
to figure out what works well with these
media what can they do really well
better than we could do let's say in
face to face conversation what is it
that they can be very dangerous about
and we need to map this and that's
something that we talk about
occasionally but we haven't really
seriously tried to come to grips with
and I would argue there's another thing
that has changed and we call that design
thinking so it used to be that the media
we had and the information we had were
kind of a given and we're very hard to
change before the printing press
probably more than after but nowadays if
you think that that snapchat to allure
the Facebook or the other tools that
you're using or not the ones you want to
use you actually are empowered to learn
how to program and do your own and so I
tell my children our student a lot about
that when you walk through the world
with a designer's perspective you look
around you said those monitors are
placed very nicely but those lights you
know maybe you should shoot them over a
little bit or this app doesn't work for
me this obviously was designed by white
guys sitting in a garage in Silicon
Valley and that's not me impersonating
someone else that I have very different
needs right and then then you don't have
to say well there's nothing there for me
what you can do is you can learn how to
program we now in New York City start in
high school to do that CS fall for
better or worse I mean there are
arguments poor against but the Design
Thinking argument would be we give you
the tools to change the world around you
start a new company we have incubators
here all over town and make it a
not-for-profit if that's what you
believe in but but think about the world
is something that can be changed and
media in the world can be changed and to
me that is super exciting to come back
to the positive side a little bit
that is super exciting because that
didn't used to be the case i given the
perhaps the positive side didn't
Socrates complain about writing down
text because he thought that that would
destroy the skill of memorization I mean
how do you respond to that this is just
that complaint over and over again in
terms of your concerns about deep
reading for example or I mean there is
evidence you know there was a article on
the cover of Atlantic that was one of
the most read called
as Google making us stupid and his
experimental evidence that if you use
would they allow people to use Google
earlier and primed them that way they
did worse in terms of they were lazier
in terms of remembering facts later on
so but obviously there must be some
upside there's you know the world's
information or fingertips so what's
different for Humanities and for deep
reading and writing alright so you
wanted me to start with Socrates I'm
happy to begin there you have to
remember it was an oral culture it was
an oral culture in in attic Greece it
was an oral culture in Rome was a lot of
writing in Rome anybody learned Latin
there was a lot of writing but it was an
oral culture was an oral culture in it
used to be called England now the UK up
through really Shakespeare's time
Shakespeare's plays although they were
written down so they were scripts so
that people could learn their parts they
were meant to be performed and only when
after Shakespeare's death and some of
the members of his company put them
together in the so called first folio
around 1623 I think was it said read
them now okay because it was an oral
culture okay so when Socrates says her
memory is going to go remember it this
was a time when certain people would
know the Iliad they would know the
Odyssey by heart thank you okay
we live in a different time writing
really seriously began for bureaucracies
for keeping track of records literature
is a johnny-come-lately for writing
philosophy depending upon how you want
to think about it because Socrates
didn't write this
Plato did by writing we were able to sit
and reflect on what was written and a
lot of things have been I think
appropriately argued that says one of
the benefits of writing is you can come
back to it you can contemplate it you
might stand up and walk around for a
while and then you come back to it
the thing about digital technologies is
it doesn't encourage our coming back
well so here's a question so if Socrates
was kind of looking ahead at the way the
world changed he'll be very upset that
there's nobody who's out there in the
world who's memorized The Iliad whereas
we go about our lives and nobody's
particularly concerned about that what
he I don't know I will know I don't know
but say say that if he was upset about
the idea that there was some sort of
degradation of mental faculties based on
memories down something talking about
with memory he wasn't talking about can
you think through a problem let's
remember he's in the really early days
of Greek philosophy hmm well so so I
guess what I'm saying it the way that
I've always interpreted that quote isn't
there's sort of a value judgment on it
right that he's not happy about the way
that things are going so to speak and
that he might be valuing different
things in an oral culture than we would
value now so I guess the question that
I'm getting at is is it possible that we
won't be having these conversations
twenty years from now because what we
value may not be your ability to answer
questions about something that you've
read but it may be your ability to look
information up and to know where to find
it I mean I'm being a little bit
provocative on purpose yes you're
hitting it right on the head what I
think is it's challenging today is we
are tending to let our technologies
reshape what we think learning writ
large should be about and there are many
people who say if you can learn to do a
good search that's much more important
than what you have in your head I think
of the study that you've just mentioned
that says if you've done a Google search
on topic X and then I ask you what you
know about topic Y as opposed to another
group of people
who have not done a Google search on
topic X but I ask you about topic why
the people who have done a search on
Google for X will tell you they know
more about topic why not having done any
search than the people who didn't have
that I know how to do search therefore I
must know all the substance that's in
the search so I think what we're doing
is defining ourselves down in a very
negative sense we don't have to do this
we're doing it by default because the
easiest thing to do with the internet is
do a search and to feel you that you
know something we know that when
students write papers they will cite as
their sources the first page in a book
some will cite the first three pages
something from the first three pages
almost nobody cites anything later in
the book okay so this is even with print
books digitally you go and one of my
students do and I ask them a question
for an online discussion they say oh
we're in the article is that topic that
you asked us to talk about and they read
the line above and the line below and
they talk about it they say one done no
no I just wanted to push push slightly
back on on one thing which is as a
learning scientist I would say if I want
someone to read the full article I give
them an assessment or a task that
requires reading the whole article right
so if I make it meaningful to someone
when you read this article you can solve
this problem they read your article or
they can solve the problem so I think we
should as as faculty as professors as
teachers take on the challenge to say
how can we make what we think of as a
test of an assessment of a measure for
how much we learned how can we make that
more meaningful and I think a lot of the
they only read the line with above on
the line below is that people are
actually very smart in understanding how
that question needs to be answered and
we learn that from games you would think
that people play games the way we
designed them and then you're shocked to
you that people game the game which is
if you if you design a game that has too
many rewards in it people will find a
way to get those rewards if you design a
game with very few rewards where you
might get the occasional star or so but
you get actually
when you do the task in the game well
whatever it might be flinging birds at
pigs or so right well if you do that
well you actually get something that
matters to you maybe just in the context
of the game but something that is that
is in that moment personally relevant
and meaningful to you then you'll expend
the energy if you just get the sense
that if I do this one thing right on the
test and then I can move on then we
don't right and so so the challenge is
that but I but but the point is so well
taken that technology is shaping us and
that is disempowering in a way that we
shouldn't let it right and so we're
struggling with that because there's so
much if I didn't change you one time my
favorite book came out a long time ago
on this issue is Neil postman's
Technopolis wonderful book wonderful
read probably only the first chapter
that people will ever read but but I
thoroughly enjoyed it and and and one of
the simplest examples that he gave and
and that should make everybody pause
this we used to sit down at family
dinner and we would have dinner right
and nobody would knock at somebody's
house to come and interrupt dinner but
when the phone rings everybody jumps up
when we still had to go to it and pick
up the phone and and so there are things
that intrude in what used to be family
life or life in general that we really
have to ask ourselves is that worth
giving up or is that really something
that we want to retain and and obviously
opinions will vary on what we can and
shouldn't give up but people walk into
traffic to a pedestrian traffic deaths
up by what ten percent or so and people
attribute that to people just airing
their phones and if just walk around
here and y-you you'll see a lot of
examples of that people will sit in
restaurants across from each other both
on their phones and deeply engaged in
whatever they're doing just not with
each other and so where do we want to
push back as a culture as a society as
parents and say when we still can and
say look this is this is something that
that we don't want to have right and
it's it's very very hard but we can't
give up we have to we have to keep
fighting the good fight I think the
debates in these discussions I think
we're at a phase where we are
recognizing that
are important than powerful tools but I
also think that those dis debates and
these concerns are letting us become
sort of like catching up with technology
and I think we look at history that is
the way that it goes that when something
new is brought out there is a little bit
of time and there's a gap between like
really learning how to use it well and
effectively and one part I'd like to be
able to also bring out it it's not only
that I'm working on teaching kids about
using things effectively and well and
having them be cautious
I do think from the perspective of
parents and adults we have to do the
same because there's a good amount of
indications that when adults are not
using these materials appropriately
indirectly they're also harming their
kids there's a there's a fair amount of
studies that are being looked at right
now with regard to parents use of phones
and and connections with out connecting
with their infant kids and and kind of
like giving their kids these these tools
too early so they don't get advantages
of little burden on that I want to ask
you one last question Richard we're okay
with the audience which is that the
American Society of pediatricians
recently revised their regulations used
to be zero
a digital media for those under two
years age and now they've relaxed that
is that the right policy I think so I
think it's well founded and reasoned the
concern had been based upon work that
had been done that found that kids at an
early age would inhibit their their
attention and their capacity of being
able to pay attention but more
subsequent studies indicated that well
it's it's so it's within reason it's
fine and I think this is what is
happening we're coming to reasonable
understandings of how to use things and
I think that that's what happened with
the Academy of Pediatrics and I also
suspect that part of it happened because
many of the people involved as they got
a younger cohort started to say well
this really doesn't seem like it could
actually happen so what butter butter
what can really be reasonable ways of
ensuring that kids who don't learn these
technologies and yet aged are going
behind their peers exactly exactly right
there'll be a digital divide which would
be inappropriate as well
so we have about 10 minutes for
questions from the audience also in the
back okay this is more of a question
about adults and social media I suppose
but I asked my dad this a long time ago
whether because he had just gotten onto
Facebook and was talking to people he
hadn't talked to in 20 years
they both immigrated ages ago and I
asked whether it was better to forget
about all those friends that you have
met you had met 20 years ago and let
them fade out of your memory like you
would have before for social media or if
it's better just to check in and know
this shallow bits of their lives without
being involved in them because
ultimately want which which is more
painful which is sadder and he never
really gave me an answer to that and I
always wondered from a neuroscience
perspective what works is it better to
have a social of shallow understanding
of other people's lives or just let them
fade away so I think the question that
you're asking you're talking about a
value judgment right is it better or is
it worse and this comes up again and
again is there's never going to be this
universal idea of what is better or
worse if you're talking about emotions
or your particular experience that you
have there may be some people for which
having those connections long term being
able to maintain them having though it
may be shallow a continuing connection
with someone is better or worse I think
there's this hope that we have that we
can look in the brain and suddenly it
will become objective right is that
because it's science because it's
something that's physical or biological
we can use all of these words and say
alright now we're getting from this kind
of touchy-feely psychology stuff where
it's just whatever you think - alright
now we're gonna look in the brain and
unfortunately that's or maybe
fortunately I don't know if it's
unfortunate but it's just not how the
brain works I mean the one thing I will
say it's really incredible about our
brains is that they're very good at
adapting to all sorts of different
situations and in fact there are a lot
of developmental cognitive
neuroscientists and I'm one of them who
think that there's something really
special about the adolescent period that
our brain is very sensitive to our
social sphere because we're learning
about our particular culture and so
something that's going to be valued very
highly in my culture the number of
friends that I have the way that I
interact with people may be very
different from what's valued in another
culture and it's this wonderful thing
that our brains allow us to figure that
out it can be very tough when as you age
your culture starts to change and the
way that you grew up is now very
different but all that is to say that
the brain is never gonna tell you
whether it's better or worse and in fact
for these questions sometimes it's
better to ask yourself or to ask
somebody else sometimes what we think of
as being more touchy-feely is actually
going to have more of a direct effect on
our outcomes and help to guide our
behavior a little better time for one
last question
my question is we've talked a lot with a
lot of the conversations been Rev you
kind of taken us to this point but if
you just roll forward what would be the
headline ten years from now so what's
the impact you see on learning and how
are behaving I take a first shot I'd
rather not go ten years because I don't
know what I could see but five years
perhaps and I'll start with the example
of digital versus print it was widely
predicted around 2011 2012 that print
really was going to fade and what has
happened instead is we've really reached
what's known as a both end world there
are certain things that we do digitally
all the time there's certain things that
we're doing a lot in print and that's
not just one person or another person
it's independent bookstores are coming
back and if you look at sales figures
and growth levels for digital books
versus print books print books has a
higher growth rate than digital does and
audio is way higher than both of them I
think the same thing is going to happen
and maybe it's because of the settling
in period four are coming to grips with
we get to control what we do with the
devices we get to control what the
devices are we get to make our own
design
I think we're gonna get tired of being
shallow we know that people who spend a
lot of time on Facebook often either
feel depressed because everybody looked
better than they did or so they think
or what came from those three hours
zilch and at some point you know our
education patterns change or social
patterns change and I think at least
within five years we're going to see
more of a balance and more a feeling
that we're in control of what we're
doing and we'll have a range of choices
and feel we have the right to make those
choices I love that as an answer but I
think in five years we will have had two
more waves of new technologies that all
promise to solve all of our education
and that then only ended up adding to
what we have available is our at our
fingertips at in our arsenal as teachers
if you want to now have to choose which
way of teaching and learning is the best
way for me for particular subject for
biddable particular context etc so I am
unfortunately as much as I love your
version more than mine
I think we're gonna be faced with this
ever-changing technological world we
live in where we're new interventions
and inventions will come out that will
challenge us and so we need to be up for
the task we need to to be ready for that
and how to do that would be probably the
topic for another panel I think it's
important also to say that technology is
not its own realm
Sooey generous or isolated from other
changes going on in society whether
that's changing age structures in
society as we age because of low
fertility rate or rising economic
inequality the changing nature of work
prolonged adolescence which is
formalized by Obamacare where kids can
stay in their their parents health
insurance until is it 25 or 26 so we
can't talk about the future it's hard
enough to read the present and almost
impossible talk about the future at all
certainly in isolation from from other
forces that are at work that we can't
so thank you to everyone for attending
this evening thank you again